Trump's highest energy moment was when
he talked about anti-tran stuff and he
even acknowledges wow people really like
hearing this nonsense in critical race
Theory transgender insanity
and other inappropriate racial sexual or
political content of our children
standing ovation
it's amazing how strongly people feel
about that you see I'm talking about
cutting taxes people go like that
talking about talk about transgender
everyone goes crazy that is an
unbelievable statement Trump is really
summarizing in that statement the
absurdity of his own movement they don't
care about actual policy they care about
trans culture War anti-woke nonsense